hey guys i'm ryan name cat and today
we're gonna watch the trailer for
deliver us than evil I got some people
telling me that I should watch this
trailer and I thought who better to
bring on than a hot as a babe to watch a
horror movie with me hopefully she
grabbed onto my arm and I hold her and I
protect her and she's like wow
Ryan is a warrior Olivia the other way
around that is most likely good night
crying I'm like it's okay I am very
emotional
it's almost over mm-hmm that sounds a
lot more like me all I know is Erik
betta is in this Stannah what a cool
name Eric Bana
it's like banner butts sling right what
up Bana he's Australian but he always
plays Americans now that's not true
actually ever since he did the whole
he's kind of just disappeared okay so
this is the guy that played the Hulk
yeah he played the the first Vulcan
inglese Holt okay the one that no one
liked and then he was in Troy another
great historical piece and then he was
it oh yeah you said he played Hector he
played hacky your horse's tamer of
horses serenity sexy stuff man Jerry
said this movies co-written and directed
by the guy who worked on sinister no
it's written and directed by the guy who
co-wrote and co-directed since ah so
this should be scary
covert sinister you directed it what
okay Jerry's not in the video but he
wanted to provide us with some fun facts
today all right so here we go we're
gonna watch this trailer I hope I get
scared I always get the same feeling
with horror movies it's like being on a
roller coaster it's always like and
you're like why the [ __ ] did I agree to
do this yes yeah so I think it's like
when you're about to get a shot and the
anticipation is almost worse than you
actually feeling the shot yeah it's kind
of like having sex with a really fat
girl and then right before it's about
the end you're like what am i doing
dammit what happened you a lot this
happens to me this is the only thing
that's ever happened to me yeah what's
wrong with fat girls I mean it's fun at
first but then you know you just kind of
want to go out in public I'm just
[ __ ] there's some beautiful big women
out there there are some beautiful big
woman yes they're just not
Ryan's personal tastes no no I know
better off I have been attracted to
bigger woman before yeah no judgement
here every K you're like an incredible
thank you I appreciate you but I accept
all body types you do you don't accept
my body type what are you talking about
when you see me you well you go bill
whenever you see me with my shirt off
yeah one time she vomited just right
away I was like I took my shirt off and
then immediately puked it wasn't even a
building I don't even remember any of
this happening yeah you blocked out I
blacked out you blacked out but they
roofies like what no yeah that's how I
normally get should you stop coming here
for something I don't know what's going
on no no no you're not gonna remember us
filming anything tomorrow don't worry
about here we go so ever us from evil
scream yeah Oh Jerry Bruckheimer does
everything two types of evil in this
life officer sergeant secondary evil the
evil that men do
and primarily evil which is okay that's
in time I've seen some horrible things
nothing I can't display by human nature
and you're having seeds from evil this
eerie music oh that sounds interesting
give daddy kisses shadow we can't we
care about him because he's a father the
[ __ ]
don't do it don't do no God stupid kids
never looking no no no no no okay all
right
oh [ __ ] it's continuing oh what the [ __ ]
like the thing from Princess Mononoke be
like way creepier good scratching noise
into the floor
there's a creepy trail around yeah it's
pretty good Oh
[ __ ] okay jump little devil it's
that devil we're never us I get it I get
why it's called deliver us from evil now
that looks pretty scary
I like that trailer it's like a clip
that was really interesting classic evil
spirit invading our home type movies
yeah it doesn't look like some you know
bloody horror fest it just looks like
it's about scares and I like I prefer
horror movies like that for a lot of
those eyes Jerry Bruckheimer did this
that's probably gonna be like an
action-packed horror film a good solid
horror film to take your family to yeah
exactly exactly you know I'll just sleep
in the same room that night and no one
will go to the bathroom yeah no dude I
hate going to the bathroom alone
whenever I watch it what do you I
remember being a kid like after we're
like we'd watch a scary movie in a
sleepover I'd like have one of my
friends like can you just go with me you
know yeah
stand outside like listen repeat you
know hi I would love to do that for you
oh god you know I actually wasn't that
scary I think I'm okay yeah always
rejecting always rejecting what is that
can't you see that what am I supposed to
be looking at this says subscribe on it
oh I should probably tell you them yeah
yeah subscribe what these are gonna
comfort it's right above cat right now
that's cool I'll use that magic to just
make it appear I know magic and magic
hands cat remember that deliver you from
people not that doesn't make any sense I
don't I don't get it I'm sure there's a
pun or something there's gotta be some
fun it's something yeah yeah deliver us
from being meanness loneliness I don't
know is that what you need deliver us
from I don't know I'm getting weird it's
getting too uncomfortable yeah yo this
guy you always gotta make there looking
awkward yeah I know I do
let's change everything on faulty